♪♪
There have been rumors of an
alliance at the edge of the galaxy.
There’s a tremendous amount of detail
that’s required
in bringing Foundation to life.
This season is a lot bigger
than the first season in scale and scope.
Everything’s so detailed.
Everything’s put together so well.
It's insane.
The wardrobes, the set designs,
they’re all completely brilliant.
We show this factory
progression of technology.
Roughly speaking, it takes us
two years to make a season.
Figure six months for pre-production,
seven to eight months of filming and
then close to a year of post-production.
Because we have so many visual effects.
Our real goal on this show is to get
people that scope that they don't
expect on television.
♪♪
Hang on!
(Grunting)
♪♪
And, action!
When I started Foundation, I decided that
I want to film as much of it
on-location as possible.
I want the crew and the actors
to feel the heat, to feel the wind.
Because I felt that it would just
make everything feel more real.
Smart boy.
Season two is very much a story of
asymmetrical warfare.
The Foundation compared to Empire is a spec.
but, slowly but surely, the Foundation
is gaining influence.
They’ve grown, and they’ve
taken over the outskirts of the galaxy.
♪♪
The sets and the locations that we’ve been
on for both seasons have been
picked out so incredibly.
It helps us create the world and it makes
it so much easier to be in the moment.
Season two goes all over the place.
There are a lot of new worlds
and they’re all very different.
We’re able to find all these new planets
and give them a unique look.
♪♪
We’re gonna return to Trantor.
In Ireland, we had the main palace sets,
the original Mural of Souls,
and we built a new clone tank set.
We’re also back in a different Synnax.
A Synnax that’s completely
covered in water.
♪♪
The world of Ignis, we had the
jungle in the Czech Republic,
but there are oceans in Ignis.
So those scenes were shot in the Canaries.
I spent three days on sand dunes, and
it was miles away from everywhere else.
But we have so much fun on set.
I love every second of it.
We’re in the Summer Palace.
We wanted the elements in
this set to make it feel like
we were in this encore lot-type
of jungle palace.
Whoever’s in charge, please can
we end this charade?
I thought you might be the one to notice.
Terminus, where the Church of Seldon is,
was actually shot in the old Skoda factory
in the Czech Republic.
Terminus city is in Fuerteventura,
and it’s just so real.
It’s in the middle of an empty space,
and they’ve built a village.
It’s not difficult to imagine
you’re on a barren planet.
A lot of the locations that we’ve chosen,
the population in North America have
not seen or don’t know about.
So that lets us spend more time in
those locations
as our backdrops for all of the
storytelling, as if it’s an alien world.
And we’re always trying to push the
look of the show.
♪♪
Wow. Look at you.
The fashion in season two,
it’s just fantastic.
Our costume designer, Jane Petrie,
she and her team had to come up with
thousands upon thousands of costumes.
We’re flying through nine planets,
there’s no through-threads, so we have to
come up with a whole new concept for each
planet and a new backstory for where
the costumes have come from.
One of the things that we really wanted
to do with season two with our
costumes was just explode
the color palette.
We’ve got these wonderfully
lush reds that are
embodied by The Church
of the Galactic Spirit.
You’ve got these kind of rainbow colors
that are embodied by Cloud Dominion.
Compared to season one, it’s been really
good to get outside more.
It’s a little bit brighter.
We go to more planets, so
there’s a lot more variety.
♪♪
Welcome to Trantor.
This season’s Day is completely
different than last season’s.
Day has turned in his blue armor.
He’s gotten a little more flamboyant.
Lee's wearing chainmail this season.
Seldon!
Allow me to present,
the doyen of the Trade Leagues:
Sareth the First. Sole descendant
of Dominion.
♪♪
Cloud Dominion.
(Ship lands)
They come from a place where they produce
the best pigments in the galaxy.
All the imperial blues in pure form.
♪♪
We had two slices of agate and worked
them into our print.
And we had these big billowing robes.
The look of Queen Sareth and Enjoiner Rue
and all of the Cloud Dominion is different
to anything I’ve ever seen.
Cloud Dominion is the exact opposite
of what Trantor is,
which is blues,  classics
and everything is so strict.
And then you have these women come
into this universe and everything is
billowy and feminine.
♪♪
What brings you to our world?
For season two, the location that really
has embedded itself in costumes
would be Ignis.
There’s an awful lot of the environment
around them that
I felt would really be part
of their clothing.
And then we worked with all of the colors
of the plant life and the vegetation.
We need your help.
I like my plan wherein we
keep to ourselves.
♪♪
Foundation is the most complex show
in terms of post-production of any project
I’ve ever been involved with.
On average, we have about four thousand
visual effects shots per season.
(Metallic sound as gun extends)
The goal is to get everything photo-real,
to get spaceships to move like we think
spaceships would really move,
to get our creatures to have the same kind
of fidelity
that any kind of animal
would in our world.
(Growl)
They have stories in me. Many stories.
Would you like to hear one?
Demerzel’s dungeon and how she’s been
split into pieces
was based on the idea that she can heal
herself and make herself
whole at any point.
So the prison had to reflect that she
could be kept separated by glass panes.
And her circuitry was then sandwiched
between them.
And then, on the outer slices,
was her human form front and back.
And painted her circuitry onto these glass
panes with LED lighting to make it feel
physical, and then my team will go back in
and we’ll augment
and give it that little
bit of extra love to make it feel real.
We probably spend a couple of weeks
coloring each episode.
Going through shot by shot, trying to make
everything as artful as possible.
It’s a highly technical process.
You an change the mood of the scene by
making it darker and blue.
Sometimes they’re shooting over three days
which,
one day it’s raining
and the next day it’s not.
So integrating all of those shots back
together with visual effects shots
requires a level of intricacy and detail.
♪♪
(Rock door opening)
And then you’ve got sound.
We’ve got a sound team called Sound Dogs,
who are incredible.
Our job is to help supplement and
exaggerate a lot of the visuals
that we’re seeing.
I think just a little at the head
and then you’re good.
This year there’s beaches, so now you’re
dealing with waves and sounds that are
clobbering the dialogue a bit
so you’re trying to clean all
that up before Tyler’s part and his crew.
They’re creating sounds of ships
that don’t really exist,
creatures that don’t exist.
(Creature moaning)
You’re building a sound
world from scratch.
There’s always a sense of discovery
in this process.
I believe that post-production are
one of the things
that really makes Foundation feel
different and more cinematic
than your average show.
♪♪
I think that’s kinda cool. Nice job guys.
Only Empire commands the stars.
Crush them. Now.
Shields forward!
♪♪
(Gun's firing)
I can’t wrap my head around the
craftsmanship on this show.
The attention to detail is
just extraordinary.
That you could only really get
on a production like this.
(Screaming)
The stakes are much higher in season two.
The galaxy has a countless
number of planets.
Ten thousand inhabited worlds,
so we see more from this season.
I didn’t think that it could
get any more vast.
And somehow, some way the team
has made it even bigger.
In season two, the rocket takes off.
And we’ve been having an absolute blast.
♪♪
It is such an incredible spectacle,
and I’ve never seen anything like it.
It’s time Empire had a reckoning.
I am so grateful and lucky
that I get to be a part of this.
And I think we really succeeded
in season two, and it was a real
treat bringing it to life.
Get us out of here!
♪♪
Woo!